my mentor um his name was frank wesley
he was interned in in buchenwald he was
picked up by chris uh by the nazis on on
kristallnacht
and he he
became a psychology uh professor
fascinating man fascinating history
he told me and he was a behaviorist um
and a behaviorist is someone who
believes that you can control
behavior by looking at it in terms of
stimulus and response
oversimplified but basically so he told
me this unbelievable story
so there was a kid and i think if memory
serves me correctly this kid was in
washington
and he kept punching his face like this
and they tried everything but they
couldn't get this kid to stop punching
his face
and so what they did was they put
electrodes on his arms and when he
brought his hand up there
they they zapped him
it only took two zaps
on um
two zaps for this kid to stop punching
himself in the head
now
frank had this on
um
on on vcr i don't know if any of your
we're maybe older than older than you
but if vcr is like these analog tapes
then they're not digital
and so i don't know maybe you should i
don't people will people even know what
it is they don't know what vcr is yeah
okay okay so so um
so
the the the tape had a a glitch in it so
he sent the tape down to the av or
whatever i t places that fixed it
and the i the the place reported
the tape for having content which um
displayed human cruelty it basically
violated a rule
and so they literally cut the piece of
the tape out so you don't see the guy uh
punching him but you can see the
electrodes and they also cut out the
section that even explained that
so
we so that knowledge is then lost to the
rest of humanity because it's viewed as
cruel and whether or not you think it
should be lost that's that's another
story
yeah
but the idea is that
you can see how our institutions based
upon values that people have determine
the outcome of what people think is true
there was just something that came out
recently about dog training i can't
remember the name of it but you can put
it on your screen that that you know uh
there shouldn't be any punishment a big
of a dog i can't remember the name of it
but uh
plus said you you know there's dog
training shouldn't have any punishment
at all it should be our reward okay so
that's ideological that's not
evidence-based so what happens now is
the the people for example in the
behaviorist with the kid punching
himself in the head or woke ideology or
microaggressions or any of this stuff
all of that is then fabricated it's it's
it serves it lives in service to an
ideology and not in service to the truth
and then people
take this information and they they
believe it because they think it's true
and then they get out and they they
bring it to the workplace they talk
about it to their friends so the whole
society is harboring some delusions
about things
does that make sense yes it does yes it
does so let me ask you does this become
the story that you told is that
selective
that's not selective hearing it's a
selective teaching is it selective
influence is it controlling
uh a part of the information to
help you come up with a different
conclusion and how often is that done
you know in accutane academia
well it's done
the reason it's done is because people's
moral minds override their rational
minds
now
look i'm not saying that
i mean
it's there's a reasonable conversation
to be had and i'm not really sure which
side i fall on you know about dr
mengele's experiments on jews and should
those you know when he broke bones over
and over again should we look at that
uh
and use that to benefit humanity or is
it it was just so utterly monstrous it
shouldn't even be considered
we can have that conversation but the
point is that
we're tr we're all doing our best to try
to create systems here that are fair and
just
and
although they're not trying to create
systems that are fair they're trying to
create systems that are equitable but
we're trying to do the right thing and
when you try to do the right thing
often you're you're living in service to
an ideology your moral mind is
truth is no longer your north star right
so so the the purpose of the institution
hasn't become defined what's true it's
to replicate the dominant moral
orthodoxy
does this strategy work to work today
meaning like the direction they're going
with vocism with equity with gaslighting
we're confusing the hell out of all of
us and pinning us against each other
is this a proven strategy long term
because you know you're seeing some what
you're starting to see as well is how
people on opposite sides are sitting
there saying
i disagree with my party what they're
doing i also disagree with my maybe we
got more things in common than before
i'm not sure this approach
maybe it worked 200 years ago maybe he
worked a hundred years ago do you think
an approach like this is going to work
today in america
well it's it's i'm shocked by the
question it's already worked it's
astonishing long term you think long
term this is sustainable yeah long term
no i don't think so yeah i agree yeah
in fact it it it is utterly it is
utterly impossible to sustain itself
long term you would need a kind of
tyranny
you know you would need to up and
totally up and free speech but it's
interesting if you look at surveys for
example from the foundation for
individual rights and education yeah
it's great danov's organization one in
four college students believe that
violence is acceptable to college
lecturers
the that's an astonishing to guest
lecturers who come in it's an
astonishing number of people who don't
feel think 40 percent don't feel they
can ask questions or uh ask difficult
questions if it's on a moral topic i
mean it's across the board we're seeing
people we're seeing this this effect
incredibly successful in the short term
but not successful i don't think so
because if you think about what happened
in in canada toronto when the university
of toronto i think it was when they came
out with the trends here's what we're
going to be doing and the controversy
with jordan peterson
let's take that out let's say that event
doesn't take place do you think jordan
peterson is as famous as he is today
think about it take that event out who
is jordan peterson so so i think what
they're also doing is they're giving
birth to jordan peterson to gatsa to you
know people like yourself to the rogans
of the world they're they're getting
others to say to a russell branded the
world or bill maher of the world to some
people that maybe they would have never
given birth to they're like wait a
minute this just doesn't make a lot of
sense to me i'm backing off because i no
longer agree with you because we're not
on the same page so i just don't think
long term
this approach of bullying is sustainable
because to what what is the power of a
free thinker if you think about a free
thinker what it what's their dna they
question things they're curious
and they typically
don't stop at no they don't stop at mind
your own business so they don't do well
with bullies they typically
stand up to bullies and eventually
bullies can bully the regular guys
they're like okay i don't want to have
any conflict but until you face a free
thinker like okay i don't like messing
with this guy he's different so you're
going to give a lot of birth to free
thinkers like jordan peterson over the
next decade because i just don't think a
lot of the free thinkers are going to
stand alone stand stand there and just
say you know we're going to take all the
bullying from you i see that not taking
place
no no no that's right and jordan has
done an amazing job of that my my friend
gad has done an amazing job of that
uh so the question is how do we empower
other people to stand up and fight back
against this ideology that's one one
question
not only is this not sustainable listen
nobody likes living like this
nobody likes being petrified of what
they can say yeah but people have been
canceled because they were bullies in
grade school
are you freaking kidding me they were
bullies when they were six and now that
you're you're denying them employment or
you're complaining to their advertisers
that they're you know white supremacist
which doesn't even have anything to do
with it
and so
not only do people not like living like
this but the question is
what damage is this going to do to our
institutions in the short term i mean
it's already done a tremendous amount of
damage by the way
you were talking about nobel prize
earlier so i went and looked up when you
were talking
uh to see who's won over the years uh
armenian uh uh bengali four people
armenian one apparently chinese 12
people hokey on one jewish i'll get to
jewish last
pashtuan nobel is one punjabi is two
tamil is three tibetan is one and how
many you think is jewish based on what
you said what do you think the number is
well the jews aren't even two percent of
the population so
uh
significantly
198 people
of nobel prize laureates by ethnicity
198 i mean the numbers are staggering
and another article just came out
yesterday that uh by uh
the head goron hansen head of royal
swedish academy of science sciences said
they want people to win because they
made the most important discovery we
will not have gender or ethnicity quotas
says top scientists interesting good for
them yeah well i mean that's a that's a
merit-based system and again so so the
question is
two questions one drill down the data
and you'll find that they're
overwhelmingly ashkenazi jews and
they're overwhelmingly from certain
region region of the planet but the the
question is well why is that the case
that gets us a little far afield in our
in our topic but i brought that up
because
um you you can't say that it's if you're
on the woke left you can't say that
biology has anything to do with it so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you